this podcast and every other podcast I
make is brought to you by our supporters
on patreon this particular episode was
available on patreon early ad free and
as an extended version there's basically
an extra discussion at the start that I
didn't include on the YouTube version
though of course this is not going to be
the norm or anything you definitely do
not have to support but it means a lot
and it helps me create these unique sort
of Niche games industry podcasts that I
make so thank you so much if you do
support and if not check out the link in
the description hi Mike uh nice to see
you again
it's it seems like only last week we
were here it does doesn't it hanging out
so much longer ago it's I envy the time
that you get to do this podcast I
recognize we're starting probably
annoyingly late today
but if we were all in the afternoon time
zone I feel like everything would be so
much better
you think and easier to coordinate yeah
because like whenever I do like the
other podcasts I do for all of them I
just say 6 p.m
always anytime after 6 p.m is good and
everyone always makes that work because
it's outside their work schedules as
well but for you that would be like
I don't know two in the morning or
something at least something like that I
don't want to do the maths it's it's too
late whatever it is it's bad yeah
exactly this is good no I like I like I
like the chat I like the uh the energy
it's interesting like a few episodes
we've done where I've been in the states
like I feel like I'm a completely
different kind of personality like one
at 1pm so it's usually my lunch break
and so I I definitely treat it as a
lunch break actually it's kind of nice
that it's like this show is my lunch
break it's like the what used to be in
the office the sitting around the water
cooler chatting kind of thing like I
have a coffee drink right now I have a
smoothie it's kind of nice it's a good
it's a good break in the day whereas for
me it's like it's like that weird 10
o'clock conversation you have in the bar
when you've kind of either drunk too
much or not enough yep it's gonna be a
lot of games entry this week
absolutely so oh yeah when is that the
game awards right yeah so we think
Austin is going to be able to join us at
some point uh Troy Kant
but this episode will publish the day
after the game awards the game awards is
Thursday night here in Los Angeles
California
um our call time is like 3 30 P.M
that's Ollie
I'm sure a lot of people
an evening do so what is it is it like
drinks and stuff beforehand and then the
the uh
I wish no um there's a red carpet
beforehand which is what the call time
is for
um and then everyone drinks it have you
been surely you've been to a game once
I've never been together
yeah yeah wow okay so uh everyone who's
the Bridesmaids
everyone has a drink
um usually in the lobby of the
um actual theater and then throughout
the show which I've always complained is
too long and Jeff did say it's shorter
this year which I'm super stoked about
um you can't the bar closes so you have
to get your drinks in first and then sit
there for three hours so they're all
serving like drinks through the actual
no drinks or food whatsoever allowed
tables or is it like in a road it's like
a it's like a cinema oh okay but the bar
closes so you can't even like walk out
to get a drink
they keep you liquored up like you are
drinking dice I'm drunk every time Nice
Dice you've got those two bars either
side right and it's just like oh my God
there's like no people in the middle
compared to every other one GDC bars as
well not the game awards no alcohol
um which makes it long but Jeff did say
it's shorter this year so this is a
thing that I wanted to do because I
thought it would be fun
Wow Mike wasn't it crazy yesterday at
the game awards uh when
um death stranding 2 got revealed
it was a disappointment to me I thought
you didn't like it I don't like I don't
think Troy was heavily featured enough
in the death surrounding 2 trailer I I'm
there for Troy I I uh yeah more Troy for
the death stranding to
um follow-up trailers hopefully
um this is a [ __ ] game until one of
us accidentally gets it right and gets
in trouble with someone yeah I know I
was like oh wait maybe I shouldn't start
with a Sony exclusive
um very excited about uh the uh breath
of the wild 2 Gameplay that we saw
surely surely right surely
Nintendo do Nintendo do a lot of um they
revealed the first breath of the wild at
the game awards I always think of them
as oh okay I'll play I'm sure that's
really hard for Jeff to get because
obviously usually they would do direct
but I'm pretty sure that's right that's
where it was revealed originally
um I know the only thing that we that I
at least from the little attention I
paid this week because my brain is fried
uh we're getting
Jedi for one order two what is it Jedi
it's not fall in order to um
basically the sequel I saw the key all
went up right yes there's definitely a
gameplay for that which I'm super
excited to see
um they've announced that that's cool
that one has been announced the game
awards 2012. let's not leak any uh
Disney game news will not be doing that
pretty good also though have you seen
that um there's the fan vote for the
game awards
and uh I've seen
Sonic Frontiers fans on Twitter are
campaigning hard against Kenshin impact
so it's actually just these two fan
bases massively uh outvoting Elden ring
and God of War Ragnarok because they're
like Twitter communities because they're
the super engaged ones yeah
so they are currently winning I'm not
sure what the actual outcome was or
because it's largely it's it's largely
peer judged right but like they've got
like specific categories where it's
audience Awards is that right with I
don't know anything about the game
awards I'm realizing I'm incredibly
underpreferred for this episode is it
like is it
it's I think 10 fan vote so 20 fan vote
so it's basically a big media
conglomerate also YouTubers are on there
as well who get to vote and there's no
discussion like there is for baptism or
anything like that oh it's not the devs
it's press this is a specifically 100
press yeah and again YouTube has some
influences I think um and they don't
have any discussions like you do for all
the other award shows uh like every
single other one
know kind of you just throw a number at
a screen usually in like an Excel sheet
and then it gets thrown to keeley's team
and then the public votes count for a
certain percentage I'm sure it's on the
website but I don't remember exactly
what it is so it's it's numerically
derived thing yeah yeah it's certainly a
bit of a
um
popularity contest but I I suppose it's
a celebration of video games you know
that feels fine to me I don't I don't
really have problems sorry it's I think
that's fine Awards yes that's fine for
game awards is like I feel like there
are other awards that are maybe more
suited to kind of you know
Indie Darlings or kind of like like you
know aspirations towards celebrating the
art form I feel like eight Awards is
it's celebrating the industry right like
I totally agree it's more that Focus
yeah that's what it's trying to do is
just be a big old celebration of big old
video games
um which I am totally cool with but
still uh
to the Accord Academy for um nominating
Carnival Ragnarok I really appreciate it
how many how many of this prestigious
award which you massively respect are
you up for
um uh I think we're up for maybe four of
these prestigious Awards which I respect
honestly
I'm actually not sure but it's
definitely a few it's uh Game of the
Year narrative music direction oh and uh
art I think
um all of which I objectively feel are
deserved so
yeah welcome Austin hello and banjo he
came in right at the same time as you
we're very similar how you doing
I'm good I'm trying to remember how the
hell to okay stop talking I'm Mike I
know who are you people owner and uh
this is Banjo where did he go is he gone
already yes yeah don't talk until you're
recording Austin stop talking yeah I'm
trying to work out right now useless
content right now I was just so zoomed
out in Pro Tools that the playhead
wasn't moving but it's because I was
looking at like 20 000 bars at a time I
am in fact recording excellent
so awards are one three at a time or
something to that effect yeah
we've done this podcast quite a few
times at this point every year yeah it's
good it's good I like it it's like a
it's like a little Christmas tradition
it's good the fact that the opinion has
not changed at all it's we're consistent
can you talk about what you just came
from
I was doing a seminar
with the Society of composers and
lyricists forgive my chewing
um
uh oh dear God the calls coming from
inside the house
he's always there
my buddy hello oh he's got a toy on his
mouth nice oh okay
I want to make an audio only version and
see what animations come out of
the last 30 seconds of this
oh what's that who's that oh there's a
toy in his mouth yep there I have added
Internet all right
um yeah sorry what did you just come
from because isn't it wasn't it also
sort of awards related
yeah it was a panel of the this year was
the first
um the first uh the inaugural group of
video game uh I don't know why I put
that in quotes uh
the yeah the new the new category of the
Grammys uh for specifically for games
and so um they announced that a couple
weeks ago and they hustled to get
together a little panel of all the
various nominees and so it was just like
um
jump on and answer questions and and but
but uh Louise Blaine who who hosted
who's done a lot with BBC and stuff
she's she's based in the UK one of the
other composers is based there I think
all the rest are here in La
um but but they were like here's the
time slot and and and the Seas had to be
parted a lot of meetings got rescheduled
and uh and obviously I'm I'm
fashionably late today that's okay you
were nominated for
for a fire team for the aliens game it
was actually really funny because this
is the first year
um I think since literally my career
began
um well certainly the first since
Journey came out which was 10 years ago
but
um
uh I think longer than that where I I
all the things I've been working on are
the releases are staggered such that I
had no new game come out in 2022.
um it's it's it's funny
well it it is a it's an odd it's an odd
phenomenon where usually there's things
are kind of like a few months down the
road something will will be ready to
yeah to come out in we did ship an
aliens uh DLC called pathogen
um but that doesn't I don't I don't
consider that team last year
that's yeah it came out it came out over
a year ago like October but the funny
thing was because they're playing it
this year I think I think
yeah well and it and you know the
because of the DLC it kind of
um uh like there's I think plenty of
folks that picked it up for the first
time yeah this year but the soundtrack
so the the Grammys are primarily focused
on the the soundtrack album release and
the soundtrack came out almost to the
day one year after the game wow just
because of legal things and Disney
owning Fox and all kinds of stuff
related to that and then there's this
question of which subsidiary record
label under Disney is going to be the
one that kind of picks it up and then um
and then at some point it was like okay
well now we've done this DLC we may as
well wait a little bit longer uh because
then we can include the DLC and it's
sort of we don't have to think about
anything there and so then hilariously I
wouldn't have been eligible for this
first Grammy if that soundtrack hadn't
been so delayed because the album's
release date pinging off of the DLC is
the only reason I even fell within the
eligibility window
um because the game it was out
significantly earlier so it's it's a bit
of because I was actually very
frustrated I kept getting tweets all the
time people go why is there no
soundtrack album and I'm like I I
there's I can't do anything about it
it's it's not of my hands uh but it
ended up being very beneficial so it's
very funny that the year where I don't
actually have a game come out
um must be nice should should treat me
well yeah sorry I did release that
Journey album though so that was sort of
my attempt at a release this year it's
interesting because okay
one at a time kids mine hasn't arrived
yet I bought your uh the journey album
where is it
the vinyl that's very kind of you I
literally never looked at the the list
like I never kind of thumb through it
someone messaged me on uh one of the
developers I'm working with earlier
today and and and was like Hey mine just
came in the mail today and I was like I
didn't know you bought one that's yeah
great oh for the record
I did this
I did this
um kind of Quasi self-distribution vinyl
thing with bandcamp as an experiment
where they do all the Fulfillment for
you yeah so I basically send them all
the assets and do all the mastering and
they I did a test print uh little uh
listen party with a buddy of mine who
has a really nice turntable setup in his
as a composer who has has it plugged
into his studio monitors so he's able to
do kind of a nice proper listening
um and and all that but then once that's
often to the presses it's kind of out of
my hands and so literally your problem
is what you're saying like if a loan has
an issue she'd probably take it over BAD
Camp yeah vinyl vinyl at
bandcampsupport.com I think is the email
to direct your great direct your uh no
but it's true like I've done I've done
total top to bottom self-distribution
before as an experiment exhausting um it
is yeah like dealing with oh mine mine
uh hasn't arrived in the mail do you
have a tracking number and like I I did
this once years ago we made a journey
piano album where it took a bunch of the
music from Journey and rearranged it for
solo piano and then actually recorded
that as a record and I I did a CD
pressing of those and made like a
thousand and sold them all and it was
like an unending just no like and I
respect people reaching out to go hey
mine showed up and it's bent to [ __ ] or
whatever and I'm like
you know I really I I I
they have every right to to complain if
they paid for a thing and it shows up
busted I didn't do that so then I like
you have to fire then you have to claim
and yeah yeah so then you have to
message them and go okay well your two
options I can mail you a replacement
um or I can refund you and it's like
that's all well and good if it was one
person out of a thousand I'd be all too
happy to consider that the price of
doing business yeah but invariably once
you reach a certain critical mass
there's just a certain number of back
and forth where like this really
shouldn't be my job like there's people
that do this as their job and are better
at it and better equipped to deal with
it and so that was the appeal of
bandcamp's thing is they said we'll do
all of it for you
um and uh so like you know and and
really with minimal they don't charge
much for that it's kind of the ideal
scenario yeah it's awesome um but the
result is that I didn't know that they
had started shipping until today when I
started getting tagged on Twitter uh I
was like oh [ __ ] that's lit I haven't
got because I ordered a bunch of like
reserved ones uh you know to to like
there's like a charity stuff that comes
up and periodically it's just nice to
have like kind of a cash on hand and
they haven't they haven't come in fact I
haven't even gotten any kind of tracking
info or anything but I guess they'll
probably be tripping this week or
something I don't know I'm assuming some
some people have gotten them and I was
like wow your Tweet is literally the
first time I've seen how they look
physically
cool that's pretty funny sorry to fully
throw you into the deep end here Austin
and you cannot answer this question if
you want it or I can even edit it out
did you see the update to the mick
Gordon stuff
meaning like from a few weeks ago yeah
that's we haven't spoken since
we're doing this topic okay the only
reason that I wanted to ask is because
we had a pretty fair take on it I
listened back to the episode and
thankfully was like oh my god
um but so many people have asked me to
ask you how you felt about it
I mean it's it's one of those I did read
it I read the I read his entire me too
post
um very very thorough and and I commend
him I mean look I'll just say what I
said that last time we talked about this
I'll say up front I think the guy's a
[ __ ] genius
um like his GDC talk which I I looked on
YouTube it's the it's the most views of
any GDC talk they've ever uploaded it is
it's like it's like a viral video I mean
it's super interesting uniquely like
they're all interesting but I feel like
that one like they're backwards stuff
and it's crazy well and also just the
Charisma with which he delivers it yeah
you know it was I was in the room and I
remember going this is the best GDC talk
I've ever been to
um and and he and I had a panel together
I can't remember if it was the day
before day after
um that I had arranged and and someone
dropped out and I I asked him to fill in
last second and he crushed it on that as
well it was called composer confessions
of telling times we've hardly dropped
the ball on a job and how we how we
figured it out on the Fly and I got like
five guys I rolled with it right like
that's his his was amazing because he
showed up and it all rhymed he did it
like a [ __ ] Dr Seuss it was
unbelievable no way oh that's wrong the
guy the guy is the guy's Talent is is
pretty boundless and and uh and so I
have I have total professional
admiration for him uh and I I I look at
the situation and I'm like you know his
article looks quite damning
um but at the same time you know I
I know people kind of across every end
of the spectrum on this so I'm inclined
to go
I don't really feel like I should weigh
in because the truth always seems to
land in the middle of people's
perspectives you know like what I tended
to assume when reading it was
he got a lot of good evidence
the truth is probably somewhere in the
middle there's some miscommunication
that's beyond this probably
um it does sound like communication was
not great on the project regardless of
where all the various chips fall
um it does seem like it does seem like
uh you know I I I'm willing to Grant I'm
willing to assume that his screenshots
and stuff are not just blatant forgeries
no like I don't think that he would do
that the cost of the cost of being found
out for doing that would be
exponentially worse than just keeping
your mouth shut so I believe that he
believes 100 of what he said it's this
it's the account of what other people
said that you can't guarantee is true
like in that what they were thinking he
cannot necessarily accurately say they
did this because this yes
well and the other thing that I'll give
him
um
props for is he makes it very clear
it seems like his beef is very
specifically with the sort of head of
the of the of the food chain over there
and that the core Dev team and all that
he really only had good things to say
about it seemed
um because he it seemed like he really
he seemed like he had the foresight of
knowing
what might
kind of be Unleashed if if if uh if he's
not careful in his words uh and yeah he
seemed to be very careful in his words
and not just be like throwing random
grenades you know it seemed pretty
meticulous it seemed like it probably
took ages to write oh yeah because it
was very and you know I'm sure it was
vetted by lawyers and it had that feel
even though it didn't feel so very
genuine press conferencing yeah exactly
it didn't feel it didn't feel um uh
sanitized uh per se so it's one of those
where like I mean look I have friends
um at ID who I hold in very high regard
and who I believe really did everything
they could to make that game all could
be and who believe even in the midst of
all this who believe deeply in his
talents and and and all of it so it's
one of those where I look at I'm like
I just look at it and go that's such a
shame like I don't know just Obama it's
a bummer because he's great they're
great I the and the product you know
it's one of those
for all the concerns over the
professional Integrity like that seemed
to be really at the heart of what
triggered all this is it was like his
concern which believe me I I understand
this is you know I'm trying to
to to do a thing that is uh you know um
going to a have my name on it and B is
it will be built in to have a lot of
scrutiny because the first one was such
a smash success that like when you do a
sequel you don't you know like no one
expect when John Williams did when did
Star Wars he did not expect it to be a
hit
but when you're doing Empire Strikes
Back you realize okay this is now a
different situation like we are going in
with the recognition that this will have
a lot of eyeballs where it we were
praying for eyeballs the first time
obviously Doom's not quite the same
because there's an existing franchise
that was already beloved but at the same
time like I think it just was so much
better than anybody was expecting it to
be and across the board as a game and
musically that it was like okay now
doing a sequel we know there's going to
be scrutiny so I'm deeply sympathetic to
the idea that his chief concern seemed
to be I just want it to be good I just
want to be able to do a good job that
that messaging yeah regardless of any of
my new show that is lost to time or or
whatever who knows who knows where
faults lie or miscommunications lie you
know I I look at it I try to be
maximally objective and charitable in my
in my read of it but I can
I can say he definitely
uh did not seem to like he seemed to be
coming from this good faith place of as
a composer I want to do good work yeah
and the thing is for all of the
hubba that kicked all this off of like
people feeling like why is this not as
good as it's funny because I look at it
and I go
boy people are being pretty goddamn
nitpicky if you ask me like I think that
the work is [ __ ] awesome it's like to
me excellent yeah
no sorry Mike go ahead
I was just gonna say I don't like the
composer involved here I don't think I
don't think he wrote his massive post
because of the the audience reaction he
wrote it because like he's bossed
through him under the bus on Reddit
right which is regardless of any other
aspect of this you do not do that to
someone you work with I'm sorry for
someone who works for you apologies like
you've never you don't throw if someone
if you're getting a complaint from the
audience anyone who doesn't like
anything about one of our games you take
it up with me I'm not going to throw
anyone who worked for me under the bus
in public for that and yeah yeah I mean
it's pretty hard to that's unacceptable
as someone who tries to be ultra
charitable and benefit of the doubt
about everything like I just to it to an
extreme like beyond beyond perhaps
what I ought to even You could argue it
is hard for me to look at
what was put on Reddit and go anything
other than just like what on Earth was
the goal here uh other than a bunch of
things that really looked shitty I don't
know like a rational decision does it
okay done with thought and compassion
for your colleagues yeah it is odd and
my my heart again like I feel sorry for
everybody in a way that I'm like that
this had to be public I pity all of you
that this yes so so should have been a
thing it sounds like it sounds like that
was tried In fairness uh but it so
should have been a thing that we never
even knew about in an idea when I
tweeted that and naturally it got a lot
of responsible people being like no this
should be out in the public I'm like man
somebody who's like worked at companies
where something was public yeah it just
sucks like you're so anxious everybody
knows like all of these misguided pieces
and you just watch people spread lies
like it's just awful for all of them I
promise Mick isn't having a good time
now that he's published that like it
still sucks
um and sorry audience for not giving a
proper synopsis of this one usually I
give context to story but I really don't
want to misrepresent this one and it's
quite long and I haven't read it for a
few weeks so I hesitate to even like try
to explain what he was saying I'll leave
a link in the description below so you
can catch up but there were a couple of
things that I actually wanted to ask the
both of you about
um which I'd also love to our story
about but
there's a part of the blog where Mick
talks about
getting paid in minutes of work
delivered but what he gets paid for
is the minutes of work used not the
minutes of work he creates is that a
thing that either of you have
experienced in any facet of this
industry getting paid for what they use
not what you do it's somewhat specific
to music I would say is that would you
say it's fair Austin like I don't think
it's it's a conversation I only really
had with composers it's my assumption
that it's specific to music but I
honestly don't know how you know I don't
know how animators were maybe artists
like do they pay hourly or do they pay
so that varies so generally I guess
let's talk about musics over first that
specific and then I'll fill in the gaps
and everything else but Austin is that
yeah
it's certainly standard it's especially
standard on a with a AAA publisher uh
with with
um you know more double A or Indie
developers
um it's a wild west of whatever deal you
want to make but the but the
Bethesda slash you know Microsoft
Ubisoft EA Sony
uh it is very standard they're all going
to have subtle variations on this
formula but generally composers have a
rate that they ask for and potentially
is negotiated where the rate is based on
time it is per minute that you deliver
to the game gotcha okay um so what he
said was 100 industry standard insofar
as uh but they are beholden to pay for
anything that they use that's the part
that was very eyebrow raising like I I
actually
um
I'll I'll not say what it was for I've
told this story publicly but I I I had a
project where I went over of my own
volition and recorded with Orchestra and
everything and delivered to the team
beyond what that because the contract
was super specific you will write
exactly this many and it was so specific
that it said per second like they took
my permanent rate and literally
granularized it to the second and said
wow okay said if you go past this this
is the rate and so basically uh once we
signed it I was kind of like you chose
to do more because you wanted to live a
better work yeah but that was like the
game needs more like I'm sorry like even
though I wrote boatloads music I was
like there's a few things that could use
some additional coverage yeah and I I
figured I I done I did that because I
believed in the project and I was having
a phenomenal experience and my
collaborators on the development side
and on the publisher side were all
amazing and and I didn't even really
keep track I just kept writing until it
felt like it was done and then I kind of
went back and was like oh turns out I'm
like 30 minutes past my my my my amount
which is non-trivial uh amount to be
over by
um
so much trouble
well that's the thing like I I didn't
think anybody would it's way more
noticeable with your kind of work when
that were to happen you know because
obviously there's also a big Downstream
effect of like if they were to just auto
book actors for example to read lines uh
and perform scenes or even like motion
capture you can't it would never just
happen on its own it would be like whoa
whoa we got a lot of extra stuff here we
got to work out let's go but my case it
was like I'm just delivering I'm just
delivering music like they probably just
paid you for what was in the contract
well so that was the thing I did not
expect that they would audit
my deliverables to make sure that that I
like that everything was in accordance
with the contract both I think to
protect them and to protect me they look
to make sure that I didn't deliver less
like they were protecting themselves
that they weren't paying more for a
thing that had a certain minimum
threshold but also it's to my benefit as
well so I get a phone call where they go
you're you're you're quite over uh did
you know that and I freaked out because
I thought my direct boss the audio
director I thought would get in trouble
for basically failing to manage the
music and because now the audio director
had
beholden the publisher to payments that
were not agreed upon so I called the I I
made a phone call straight to the top of
the food chain and was like to be clear
I was not asked to do this I did this of
my own and I am not expecting you to pay
me for it like I did that that was a
risk I undertook yeah and I fully
acknowledge that and it's very important
to me that my direct Superior not
getting trouble for basically playing
fast and loose with the budget yeah
um and they were like no no no no no
everyone's super happy look we just
wanted to make sure the number was
correct because we owe you more money
and I was like
to be clear they also legally kind of
have to pay you
contract
I mean the context does right then they
have to pay you otherwise they don't own
it or they could have just not used the
Musical music or they could have
renegotiated a lower rate for those
extra minutes with you but honestly I
imagine if you're talking AAA it's
easier for them just to write you a
check than to call the lawyer yeah yeah
and the and the funny thing was they
were just they were so gracious about
the whole thing and I I was really
worried that my boss was going to get in
trouble and they were not remotely upset
they were they were very happy you know
because this was all very last second I
mean this was all conversations that
were happening weeks before the game
came out so it was a and I was and I was
you know and in hindsight I was like I
was very apologetic to them going I did
not mean to put you in a position that
might be feel maybe feels precarious
here like oh [ __ ] you know our we're
kind of over a barrel because we're at
the end of the project I said I was just
following my creative instincts and we
were all
vibing and having a good time and
writing music and and that's why you
know obviously if it came down between
you have to pay or you can't use the
music legally obviously obviously I I
wrote the extra because I believed that
it benefits the game and it's already
like the game was passed it's gold
mastering process and stuff at least if
memory Services was years ago uh so it
was one of those where I was like ah
okay you know I will be I will be more
transparent in the future all I will
keep better records it wasn't even that
I was hiding it it's just I didn't even
really realize I just kept writing until
it felt like we were out of time like it
was done holy for everybody really but
yeah backtrack slightly
do you get paid for minutes delivered
and they can ask for as many iterations
as sorry for minutes use and they can
answer as many iterations as they want
because that seems like you could get
put in a room there's a couple of
different schools of thought on this for
sure yeah yeah I mean there are a couple
things just that if you delivered things
they said no
and then had too many re-delivers that
he would so usually he would
contractually put a limit on those edits
right or else don't like you I don't I
actually am not I don't support that
philosophically I don't to me it is not
you're already most people would do that
most artists that I've worked with do
that in music it's a contentious subject
there's definitely a large swath of the
composer community that thinks that
there should be a this is how many
revisions before we're talking more
money
um I personally I I aspire to feel like
part of the dev team
um and I think that as a as an
independent contractor I'm already an
outsider and if I then go by the way if
you're not happy you have to pay me even
more like it shouldn't it be my fault
that you're the one who's not happy I
should be the one who says like let's
work on it until it's good now I mean
unless you work with someone who sucks
I was gonna say yes like it is
good
well in my experience the vast vast
majority have been if there's a lot of
revisions it's because we're finding it
you know like I was just talking earlier
today with somebody how on abzu for
every five minutes of music that went in
the game I probably wrote close to 45
minutes wow and and that was not them
telling me that was not Matt nava going
I don't like this do it again it was me
going I think I can make it better and
Matt going then by all means have you
had any of those experiences then well
you've worked with somebody who's
requested just like an unfathomable
amount of revisions where you were like
hold up this is not worth the effort for
me
I've never said that I I I I I I
lovingly tried Jack at Ridge on Erica
that that he was probably the hardest to
please director I've ever worked with
that doesn't shock me at all
um but it wasn't the thing was it was he
wasn't hard to please because he's a bad
director there are those I've worked
with those never in games though I've
been lucky in games in that regard
because I'm sure they exist but I've
genuinely never had that in film though
I've absolutely had directors that they
go go do this and you do it and they go
I guess that wasn't it what if we tried
that and you realize like brand deal
stuff that I've done where I'm working
for them to deliver a certain amount of
stuff and they go
make sure you don't wear a shirt with
patterns on it okay we don't like the
color you have to change the color of
your shirt why didn't you tell me the
first time to wear a specific color
shirt yeah they don't know they have
sometimes you just absolutely ridiculous
absurge like okay I guess how many of
these do I have to expect to come back
to it would be one thing if there's a if
there's a cohere if there's a thousand
Point checklist of things but it's
coming from a place of a clear and
coherent Vision that I have no issue
with that it's when it's when I feel
like I'm on the tail end of a whip uh
and I'm and from their perspective
they're doing this but out at the far
end of it you're swinging left and right
and violently jerking around but again
I've essentially never had that in my
experience working in games and that's
just the dumb luck of the people that
have reached out to me they've they've
been some combo of either really strong
Vision or they're deferring to my vision
and they're going you find it it's
probably a part of the way that from
everything you've really ever spoken
about the way that you pick what you
work on is also based on teams that you
want to work with is my understanding
you're very selective in that yeah
there's a selection it's always based on
the people above above all like if I
have a bad feeling about someone on a
personal level it can be the most
lucrative or like this exciting
professional opportunity but if it feels
like ah man this is someone that when
when you're in the trenches and like
it's that 11th hour and you know you
want to feel like it's someone that
you'd really bend over backward for
are they willing to do the same and I've
never I've never read flagged out of a
thing on again I mean there's been a
couple where
um you know it didn't I I kind of was
like ah it's insufficiently kind of
exciting or or or whatever variation of
variables overlapping
um but in film I've absolutely uh you
know like on the first meeting where a
director is like I just want you to know
I demand Perfection and I'm like okay
goodbye yeah like that is such a red
flag like I I am I also I demand that of
myself but the person that is like
aiming for this mic drop in the in the
introductory let's get to know each
other I'm like I wanna okay fine if
you're saying let's tell your douchebag
go work at a gym it's a real it's a real
yeah
I'm using that next time because in
Hollywood you run into a lot of those
kind of guys I I remember using the go
work at a gym that is I'm using that
like the funny thing is it's amazing in
my in my experience it's always the
least experienced ones that are like
this the more compensating security I'll
never forget like a student when I was
at USC and I was scoring four minute
student shorts those were the most
difficult directors of my whole career
they were like we're all like 19 year
olds that don't know anything and this
one guy I remember this one's a very
specific guy he was like you know this
is my entry point to the industry if
this isn't perfect we all suffer like
this needs to be the best work and I was
like
you don't know how much you don't know
until you know that's it
um
so
so go ahead oh let me just add one last
thing about the I I I will say I have
long decried the per minute business
model
um because I don't like that composers
are financially incentivized to add as
much music as humanly possible to a game
I don't like the idea that that because
I always use Castaway as my as my as my
go-to example but you could use the last
of us as a as a corollary example in
games where
um silence is a creative decision that
is so powerful the idea that the
composer should be financially penalized
we're going what if we didn't put music
in this scene Castaway is a movie that
has no score until the third act and
even then it's the back half of the
third act there is 14 minutes of score
in a two-hour film entirely consigned to
the last 30 minutes of the film didn't
know that and the idea that Alan
Silvestri should have been paid less
than say back to the future or Forrest
Gump or The Avengers
on the basis of doing less work when it
was a creative explorational process to
arrive at that now I get the idea that
on a practical level like it will cost
less you hire the orchestra for a day
instead of for two weeks and blah blah
blah blah that's all well and good but
but
um the idea that uh that you should
value silence less than non-silence to
me takes creative options off the table
in a way that actually harms the game
would you prefer a flat rate absolutely
yes I always say and because I don't
also like the idea of I don't think of
music as like a thing I Dole out in 60
second units yeah you know musical
development sometimes sometimes the
exact right thing is 30 seconds and
sometimes the exact right thing is is
you know like on on pathless I remember
we we
um after a lot after two years of
experimentation one of the things we
wound up with in the kind of
non-combat open world very vibey
exploration or moments of the game is
the music doesn't loop I wrote like
these nine minute pieces that just tell
their own kind of musical up and down
story and it has this vertical sort of
modulation it can do based on your
momentum and based on a lot of other
variables where you are in the world how
far you are in the storyline all this
kind of stuff but fundamentally it PL I
wrote a succession of really long pieces
that just play and have the ability to
be interrupted and have to be able to be
rejoined and blah blah but it's not just
like a loop that goes well as a result
it pushed the runtime of the score Way
Beyond what we originally expected but
it was what the game needed yeah and I
was like you know I'm not 60 seconds is
a very rigid for what should be
extremely creative
yeah and and like I get I understand I'm
sympathetic to publishers
somehow yeah and I get that and I and I
recognize that it is a very convenient
way to quantify so my ideal is always to
say
uh and I very rare on with AAA
Publishers I'm very rarely
um like granted this In fairness to them
and I will and I'll go okay fair enough
we'll play by your rules like it's not
like there's a hill I'm gonna die on uh
you know very few games are sort of the
trade-off of working on the game not
worth just going okay we'll we'll play
by the traditional rules that's
perfectly fair but the proposal I tend
to make is let's use a per minute rate
in order to figure out what we think is
a fair all-in deal and like in order to
give us a sense of scope and to just be
able to have numbers to put on the table
and discuss and then also help us figure
out now how much like how much am I
being paid versus how much are we
wanting to spend if I need to hire a
musician or a whole Orchestra or all
whatever uh like what is the cost
associated with this music as well and
then ideally
once we've kind of wrapped our head
around the overall scope we then
sign on the dotted line and and never
look again at the at the particulars and
if I if it comes in a little under or if
it comes in a little over we're
operating in a good faith place that
this is predicated on
everybody's just trying to make the best
game and I've I've come in almost always
I come in you know my agent is
ironically the one who's like let's try
to put some limitations because she
knows my my predisposition is to go
quite Beyond yeah
um and theoretically that puts me in a
position of being taken advantage of but
on a triple a publisher like I said with
the story they don't they don't even
really allow that so that's why the mick
thing
I don't again I don't know what happened
there I I I I would I don't
I don't I don't uh want to pretend to
pretend any kind of omniscience on the
situation but as described that is very
blatantly contract violating in terms of
the way most contracts are typically
written again I don't know his contract
but that would be a thing that if they
use it
um they can't not pay for it like that's
just straight that's common sense yeah
um so my sorry I might yeah sorry no no
it's a great answer that's exactly what
I I was asking um Mike I assume that
you've worked with uh contractors on any
of your games before how does it work
for other departments
so fairies um so yeah most of our Mo
we're actually we've only just through
the the recent kind of now hyper sizing
of the company we're now hiring
full-time like we were contractors
largely contractors for years and years
and years yeah um it varies and it
varies from person to person and there's
different from Department to Department
and also from Department there are
definitely like Norms but then it's also
just there's just I've heard really
compelling arguments in multiple
directions like like Austin they're like
talking about like a fixed right like
100 how I like to work with a composer
and usually that's how most of our
contracts are done and and yes we work
out like a we'll we'll start at that
number of like what's our music budget
and then we'll kind of retroactively
work with the composer to work out well
what can we get for that money what's
reasonable for you what's reasonable for
us and kind of I think that's how we
worked it with with John we've now going
into the full-on on the contract also I
think that's generally how we we get we
approach it so I assume we did the same
there but like the I actually don't
remember
I keep being told the checks in the mail
uh yeah just like I was just like my
journey final yeah
yeah you get paid when a lot of get
survivalists
this arrived oh that's so incredibly
sweet of you yeah
it's very cute she did indeed
but it's super it's super varied so the
the thing with music that makes music a
very very very special case is as we've
talked about on the show before like the
the history of like uh unions and
expectations about music rights just
being very locked in on all levels so
there's actually quite a lot of
complicated kind of contractual like
precedent and law and stuff that we all
have to work around plus you can
leverage it separate from the game when
in a way that's unique from every other
thing exactly it's its own it's its own
profit Center if you handle it profit
probably as well so there's all of those
layers I but with the other thing with
music specific to this conversation is
that the deliverables are definitely
specific to the individual doing the
work and there is an easy metric for
them so Austin turns in a soundtrack he
knows the seconds and he knows he did it
and and if you look at almost any other
job you would hire a contractor for in a
game
it's not that simple how many artists
did you work with on
um
solitaire
uh Solitaire was in terms of artists uh
there was we had uh an internal 3D
artist who did some jobs on it but the
primary or the uh uh we had a couple of
internal artists who did it did little
things on it but the main artist was Jen
who did the portraits so how and I don't
want to out yeah what was Jen's contract
well sort of like how do you approach
like she did most of the art for the
cards right so how do you approach
but like there's definitely like so
there's different approaches we could
have taken let's use the example of like
making some portraits and like the
different ways that could have been
worked out one would have been to pay
per hour so literally per hour spent on
the work
we pay a fixed rate that's largely
thought of as nice and predictable for
the uh the end for the for the
contractor it's um it's very budgetable
and and logical in terms of how that
works requires a lot of trust on both
sides but the biggest argument against
that as an approach is [ __ ] you if it
takes me an hour to draw a beautiful
image I should not be paid less it's
similar to what Austin was saying than
if it had taken me two hours because I'm
making that faster for you or you're
getting the same outcome of that work so
why do you care how long it took me to
make and how dare you like I'm fast
because I'm good and you should pay me
more so there's there's a lot of weird
arguments around like hourly rates for
contractors and and I've seen I know
contractors who go one way or another
or you could have paid per asset with
which would be more like when you've
done when you've done kind of
commissioned illustrations and stuff
along and be similar to that of like
you're paying for a piece and yes you've
got some revisions and stuff
um and then you've also you've also got
things where and in most cases with with
most video game content it's not I would
say like the cards in Solitaire are
easier to Define exactly like that's
Jen's work that's a that's a specific
thing most are made for video games is a
concept that's going to go through four
people different concept artists
Ragnarok who were like I think I wrote
that I don't remember who wrote that
like yeah and you you throw all together
and and then it goes to a 3D artist and
like should you know if your script is
being read by an actor who's being with
a different mocap actor performing it
that goes through an anime like at what
point can you quantify Alana's
contribution to that asset yeah
um so so with games most most roles tend
to go down either like a blanket we're
paying you this much for the product
project or an hourly rate that's General
I would say that's the norm for most
jobs in uh video games kind of from a
Contracting point of view it makes sense
um or but but I've done I've done
different deals and and largely I think
this is the thing that a lot of people
don't understand with with contractors
is it's a contract so there's always
room for negotiation it's similar to
like publisher developer relationships
like there is no one-size-fits-all
ultimately if you want to if I want to
work with Austin on my next game I'm
going to bend my expectations of what
that would look like in terms of
contract if he wants to work with me
he's going to be willing to bend as well
and we're going to kind of find
something in the middle that works for
both of us neither of us might be doing
our default standard but I've certainly
I've done some very strange contracts
I've done contracts where there's not
even money exchanging hands it's like a
favor or something that they need for
something else I've done I've done one
contract where I did some graphic design
for them in exchange for them doing it
was some play testing and because that
was just they they do play testing I'm a
graphic designer by traitor like in two
hours I could do a graphic design
treatment for I didn't know that about
you and that was oh yes where I started
graphic design so I have no idea so I
can do like so I so I did like a
brochure for them or something like
something like that because it's just
like oh that'll take me half an hour and
then they go and do a play test which
was useful to obviously what we were
doing so so you can find there are a
million ways of doing this in a million
shapes the one thing I would say is
um I think it it should never be it
should be done with consideration like
to what you need as a person like
obviously with Austin you're and we all
are we're in a position where we have
you know some some win in our sales some
reputation some ability to choose
projects and ability to yeah you know
take some risks
there were definitely people at the
start of their career who are much more
exploitable than us because they they
can be screwed over massively and that
would you know could force them to like
Mr and payments too like that definitely
is the thing obviously that we're in a
position where we don't have to worry as
much but I was also a contract writing
for a company and
they would send me
um
I don't know how to say it basically I
the amount of writing that I was having
to do because somebody else on the team
was inefficient me and me go to the boss
and be like hey I recognize that I get
paid hourly for all of this
but you're just this is such a waste of
money because I am having to write more
than I should ever need to not that I
have a problem with it and I can take
the money but because the way that this
is being supplied to me is so
inefficient and and redundant that it's
a waste of your money
um and I remember going to a Boston
saying that and being like this
something has to change here yes I can
take tons of money for these easy rights
but
my God is this a bad system uh and
that's and and if that boss was a good
boss I they probably would have hired
you for more work based on that like
they would have thought that that was an
impressive quality that you should show
you that like I definitely had it where
a contract has come to me and been like
you can get so much more value out of me
if you use me in this way
um and it's always something like
massively value and I'd go back to this
yeah I mean I kept working with him but
it was uh I think that I was just like
this is such a bad use of everyone's
time because again I was having to do
did they change anything or do they just
I don't think they did you know I had to
do things I basically had to do double
or even triple work because somebody
another department was operating pulling
or whatever
um so I was getting to be paid triple
the amount that I actually should for
hours that I shouldn't be working and
that was just it was just a whole mess
so you can kind of go both ways where
you can be in a position to help other
companies function a little bit
better as well if you aren't worried so
much about financial risks which I'm
sure I think we've spoken about
contracts a lot and take them seriously
that's the the biggest thing take them
seriously but remember until you sign it
there's a conversation and you can yeah
I think people well
what they need I was just like oh I'm
not gonna argue with this and now I'm
like fine tooth combing every contract
that I read
um yeah I have to get back to work yeah
same
um thanks for trying out for joining us
I probably should sleep cheers you need
to go to sleep
what time is it there now 10 it's 11.
yeah it's a late one sorry Mike thank
you for joining again
Happy game ones everybody
congratulations to Elden ring
so I assume so you assume uh and music
winner and music winner
uh all right uh we will see you next
week I'm alone I'm a video I'm ready
that's my Billy's video game director
and that is awesome videos we'll see you
next time
[Music]
thank you